[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 de l'actualité des idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans le département voici le programme
de ce 3 décembre
accompagné les habitants dans leurs
démarches administratives impôts
logement ou encore emploi c'est la
mission des maisons france service il en
existe 1745 en france une structure
vient d'ouvrir à mantes la ville près de
la place du marché mode d'emploi à
suivre c'est le week-end marathon pour
la recherche contre les maladies
génétiques rares le téléthon revient
pour une 35ème édition cette année
encore la crise sanitaire impacte les
programmes mais les commune yvelinoise
restent mobilisés invité christine le
coeur coordinatrice du téléthon à
villepreux et puis comme chaque vendredi
notre sélection d'idées pour sortir dans
le département c'est dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission
avec bien sûr bixente marien sortie
steban bonjour bixente on est noir il
avait vous à la carte aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui une petite interview du
rappeur kirtas en détente relaxe dans un
cadre plutôt atypique et aussi qui dit
fêtes de noël le premier week-end de
décembre dit bien sûr marché de noël les
fêtes de fin d'année qui arrive à grands
pas et on voit ça tout à l'heure dans le
sais tu ce week-end
l actualité d'abord avec cette maison
france service qui a ouvert à
mantes-la-ville la mission de cet
accueil de proximité accompagnés les
citoyens dans leurs démarches
administratives comment fonctionne la
structure mode d'emploi avec justin braz
et une maison francs services a ouvert
ses portes à mantes la ville située à
100 mètres de la place du marché à côté
du service d'action sociale du
département mais surtout à proximité des
quartiers politique de la ville un
emplacement stratégique le but pallier
les difficultés d'accès aux services ses
missions accueillir informer et orienter
les usagers nous pouvoir accompagner
donc les usages vers
les services qui sont en ligne et nous
aider donc allé à les remplir il ya
également une notion administratif donc
sur les démarches toutes les aider à
faire des démarches administratives
également donc en physique et donc la
plus grande des marchés orientés donc
les usagers vers les opérateurs neuf
opérateurs sont partenaires de la maison
offrant service le ministère de
l'intérieur la direction générale des
finances publiques le ministère de la
justice la cpam la cn avait la caf pôle
emploi la msa et la poste le but
accompagner les administrés dans leurs
démarches administratives par exemple
faire sa déclaration d'impôts en ligne
ou encore débloquer ces indemnités
objectif créer un lien entre les
services de l'état et ceux de la commune
pour faire leur carte d'identité il faut
se créer un compte à mts à partir de là
on les a réorienté vers france services
pour que nos agents puisse les
accompagner a créé ce compte là c'était
surtout des personnes âgées qui n'ont
pas l'habitude d'utiliser l'outil
numérique donc là on s'est posé avec eux
on a travaillé avec eux
on leur a montré comment créer un compte
nts et à partir de là on peut retourner
en mairie pour déposer le récépissé de
carte d'identité sur place un bureau de
confidentialité pour participer à des
visioconférences des bureaux de
permanence pour les services partenaires
et une salle multimédia beaucoup de
démarches maintenant ce fonds
en dématérialisé et donc
certains voire beaucoup nous administrer
ne sont pas en comment dire en capacité
de faire ses démarches au sun donc
l'idée c'est vraiment qu'ils puissent
avoir cet espace qui leur est dédié avec
des agents qu'ils accompagnent pour
toutes ces démarches administratives
depuis l'ouverture de la structure à
mantes-la-ville déjà 900 administrés
sont venus profiter des services
l'actualité du week-end c'est bien sûr
le téléthon le 35e marathon pour la
recherche contre les maladies génétiques
rares démarre ce vendredi va se
poursuivre samedi et dimanche dans les
communes yvelinoise une fois de plus
très mobilisés on en parle avec
christine le coeur bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la coordinatrice locale du téléthon
de ville brûle au rendez vous faites
cette année dans la commune ses 26 ans
on va présenter le programme dans un
instant est ce que tout est prêt déjà
pour ce week-end eh bien on l'a on est
sur les starting blocks sont les
dernières heures de préparation fait
tous les ajustements c'est une énergie
et une mobilisation incroyable sur le
terrain là pour être prêt à 18h pour le
lancement là on est dans un contexte
encore tendu au niveau 2 au niveau
sanitaire l'édition pourra tout de même
avoir lieu en présentiel cette année
j'imagine qu'à une joie de se retrouver
après une édition en distance yale oui
une joie on a voulu faire ce soir un
rendez vous festif familial le thème
lumières sur le téléthon national qu'on
a bien évidemment duquel on s'est
inspirés et la soirée demain soir par
exemple sera andré ce code mais des
paillettes mettez payet oui parce que ça
fait deux ans qu'on est contraint on a
fait une petite version de l'année
dernière et cette année on est ravi de
pouvoir se retrouver c'est un moment qui
est attendu par de nombreux ville
provient et même de communes alentour
donc voilà un rendez vous
on a tout mis pour que ce soit remontant
très agréable pour chacun d'entre nous
la joie de se retrouver juliusz le10 aux
siens c'est la coordinatrice du téléthon
dans le secteur est des yvelines elle
est sur la même longueur d'onde que vous
on l'écoutait elle était l'invitée de
mélanie poquet dans la dernière émission
sept huit sociétés alors tout le monde a
envie de se retrouver c'est vraiment à
le téléthon c'est le 14 juillet en hiver
les gens ont envie de se voir de se
retrouver de participer on sent l'envi
de cohésion que le téléthon apporte aux
familles il n'y a pas eu besoin de
remobiliser non au contraire on a eu
beaucoup de nouveaux organisateurs qui
sont venus nous voir mais qui nous ont
contactés en disant voilà j'ai jamais
fait je sais pas comment on fait mais je
voudrais participer qu'est-ce que je
peux faire donc ça a été la très belle
surprise de 2021 on l'entendait une
mobilisation toujours présente avec en
plus cette année de nouveaux
organisateurs et à villepreux 600
bénévoles cette année et toujours une
forte mobilisation pour ce téléthon dans
la connerie elle est impressionnante et
elle nous touche beaucoup puisque comme
beaucoup d'associations il ya eu un
essoufflement duo de confinement et la
main tout le monde a répondu présent
voir de plus en plus présent je pense
que c'est important de se retrouver de
se réunir de voile a de la joie le
plaisir de se retrouver le plaisir du
partage et et cette générosité cette
solidarité incroyable qu'on vit à
villepreux et c'est un rendez vous et
une édition 2021 presque normale après
l'année dernière on le disait le
téléthon s'était fait en dix ans ciel
mais tout de même 25000 euros récoltés à
villepreux on était proche des 30000
euros récoltés sur l'édition 2019 on
voit aussi que c'est un rendez-vous qui
tient à coeur aux habitants c'est un
rendez vous fort du début du mois de
décembre à chaque fois oui tout à fait
ça fait 26 ans que le téléthon existe à
villepreux on en est très très fiers et
cette année on a même fait peau neuve il
ya une association qui a été créée
l'année dernière qui s'appelle actions
de villepreux pour la roche recherche
pardon médical et
voilà c est à énormément de fidèles qui
tiennent à ce rendez vous est le moteur
de nous tous c'est donner de l'espoir à
tous ces malades pour les guérir de
maladies rares donc le vrai plus la
recherche médicale l'objectif devrait
atteindre les 30 mille euros peut-être
cette année plus que ça on espère il ya
eu tellement ri un programme incroyable
donc on a mis tellement d'énergie on a
tellement de chance d'avoir des
partenaires on a des professionnels qui
travaillent à nos côtés on a eu des
sponsors qui ont donné des sommes
indécentes que ces voix là on est
vraiment heureux on essaye d'être à la
hauteur et on attend que tout le monde
vienne c'est notre récompense en fait
que tout le monde participe et viennent
passer un moment agréable tout
simplement et puis ils font en plus un
acte de générosité on va présenter le
programme juste après justement un tel
programme on imagine que ça se prépare
avec plusieurs mois d'avancé élan plus
avec ce contexte sanitaire comment
prépare justement un tel événement avec
la contrainte co-lead alors la
contrainte qu'on vide on l'a vécu
l'année dernière puisqu'on a fait trois
programmes
l'équipe a montré beaucoup de
persévérance et de motivation et cette
année on a attendu la dernière limite
normalement on s'y prend mois de février
pour préparer le téléthon de l'année de
fin d'année là on a attendu septembre va
être sûr de ne pas avoir de contraintes
supplémentaires donc ça veut dire qu'on
travaille
j'allais dire jour et nuit mais c'est
presque ça tous les week-ends tous nos
moments on est on a une équipe de huit
personnes le bureau donc on y est on ya
passé beaucoup de temps c'est un grand
plaisir d'organiser tout ça et je donc
du coup en fait
les contraintes sanitaires en fait que
comment les respecte à un échange avec
monsieur le maire on est très vigilant
notamment suite aux dernières annonces
donc là on s'engage je me suis engagé à
faire respecter les consignes sanitaires
un peu plus restreinte on va donc pas
cela ni terre obligatoire port de masque
obligatoire
bien sûr le nez évidemment et puis
pendant le concert notamment qui aura
lieu samedi soir on va prendre le soin
d'aérer la salle toutes les heures comme
c'est recommandé pendant 10 minutes le
programme olivier le thème national
cette année ses lumières sur le téléthon
et on sera sur le thème des lumières ce
soir pour l'ouverture et une farandole
de lumière notamment qu'il est prévu oui
tout à fait mal à on voulait mettre
aussi en barque et la jeunesse avec nous
on a cette chance d'avoir une
mobilisation incroyable des lycéens
notamment toutes les écoles scolaire
donc maternelles primaires qui ont vendu
des goodies pendant toute la semaine on
a fait un pass jeunes pour les
invitations pour la participation
concert demain 5 euros pour qu'ils
peuvent vraiment ça soit accessible pour
eux et puis donc ce soir on ouvre avec
une farandole de lumière des bâtons
lumineux là qu'on pourra vendre aussi
pendant le spectacle demain soir on a
des comptes lumière de compte pour les
tout petits on a pensé à eux aussi et
puis plein d'autres attractions là on va
avoir des initiations quidditch a aussi
demain mais ce soir voilà c'est c'est
aussi on met à l'honneur une petite
fille note sarah lakiha est atteinte
d'une maladie rare et qu'on vous voulez
on voulait mettre des paillettes dans sa
vie et dans la vie de sa famille aussi
donc ce soir c'est elle va faire
l'ouverture avec nous et monsieur le
maire un mot aussi sur samedi avec
michael jackson au programme oui ça y
est on a invité les venues incroyable
non donc en effet on a une troupe qui
vient donc de professionnels
avec sabrina la tête d'une association
qui milite pour le les oeuvres
caritatives dont nous ont fait le
plaisir on a de la chance qu'ils aient
monté un spectacle pour le téléthon de
villepreux avec 27 tableaux
donc on a le sosie de michael jackson
qui vient danser est un artiste donc le
chanteur qui a vraiment à sa voix on
ferme les yeux on entend michael jackson
donc ça fait des mois qu'ils répètent
donc on a hâte de voir ce spectacle donc
les places sont encore on peut encore
acheter des places à partir de ce soir
en catégorie 1 à 6 avec une petite coupe
de champagne et puis quelques
mignardises et en catégorie 2 si vous
achetez une place vous avez une place
pour enfant offerte aussi avec ce pass
jeunes donc on attend évidemment que la
salle soit pleine ses notes c'est notre
souhait avec partager une soirée je suis
tout ça il ya de suivre à distance en
visio s'essaye au une rotation voilà
pour les gens qui préfèrent suivre le
spectacle de leur canapé c'est possible
en allant sur la page facebook du
téléthon villepreux ils peuvent scanner
un qr code et là on pourra alors envoyer
un lien a pour 5 euros ce qui est
vraiment y peuvent c'est un lien privé
ils peuvent le regarder en direct demain
soir s'ils sont disponibles ou à
distance au dimanche après-midi lundi la
semaine prochaine voilà très rapidement
programme de dimanche seront dépassés au
niveau du temps que faut-il retenir le
programme de dimanche c'est le
villepreux animation doit se dire c'est
voilà un grand un grand classique mais
c'est un rendez vous attendu de tous les
villes provient qui montre un spectacle
de danse avec énormément de danseurs et
là j'ai lu alliès
alalalala responsable l'organisatrice de
ce beau spectacle et elle était très
contente de m'annoncer qu'il y avait
plus de 150 places de vendu pour la
première séance donc voilà on est ravi
c'est un moment voilà plus intime plus
familial mais où on voit tout et proulx
est d'aider des jeunes danseurs ville
provient en effet le prochaine mais tout
ça se passe bien sûr à vil prix au même
endroit à chaque fois pour ses
animations où toutes les animations du
week-end de ce soir jusqu'à dimanche en
fin de journée se passe au gymnase alain
mimoun à ville propre et on trouve le
programme complet sur la page facebook
de téléthon villepreux merci christine
le coeur d'avoir été avec nous et bon
téléthon à vous le rappelle que vous
êtes la coordinatrice locale du téléthon
à villepreux qui fête cette année on le
disait ses 26 ans merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous de nous avoir invité
le téléthon 2021 qui va se poursuivre
aussi dans d'autres communes ce week-end
avec un programme très varié
quelques exemples compiler les voix s'il
n'y a pas tout bien sûr il faudrait plus
qu'une animation à coignières des
concerts sur deux jours et une course à
pied avec la présence de myriam et
thomas de koh lanta à guyancourt
l'événement force et la soirée téléthon
au pavillon waldeck rousseau mais des
animations sportives aussi se tienne le
dimanche aux clayes-sous-bois
l'essentiel se déroule à l'espace
sportif thierry gilardi avec en point
d'orgue une soirée musicale le samedi et
puis à voisins le bretonneux en plus des
festivités au centre sportif des
pyramides les commerçants du quartier de
la bretonnière vous convient à un marché
de noël le samedi 10 % des bénéfices
reversés au téléthon et si vous ne
pouvez pas vous rendre en présentiel sur
ses nombreuses animations n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez également donner à
distance par téléphone ce numéro le 36
37 ou sur internet dont point
telethon.fr le téléthon qui vient
clôturer une semaine riche en actualité
dans le département des yvelines que
s'est il passé du 29 novembre au 3
décembre dans le département justin
brasier vous résume le tout en 78
secondes
[Musique]
25 millions de français éligibles au
rappel vaccinal les rendez vous sont
pris d'assaut par les plus de 18 ans au
15 janvier le pass sanitaire sera
conditionnée à cette troisième dose
passe à cette forte demande les centres
de vaccination yvelinois rouvrent leurs
portes
joséphine baker a fait son entrée au
panthéon c'est la sixième femme à y
accéder la cérémonie a lieu mardi à
paris célèbre meneuse de revue mais
aussi résistante l'artiste a résidé au
vésinet elle s'est éteinte en 1975
mercredi 1er décembre marqué la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida le
nombre de dépistages en france a baissé
avec la crise sanitaire - 650 milles en
un an vingt-quatre mille personnes
ignorent leur séropositivité
hs prévention santé alerte sur les
conséquences du manque d'information des
jeunes notamment
l'antenne locale les petits frères des
pauvres fête ses trente bougies cette
année l'association oeuvre pour les
personnes âgées isolées notamment sur le
territoire de plaisir à les
clayes-sous-bois guyancourt et
villepreux et puis le mois de décembre
marque le coup d'envoi des animations de
noël dans les yvelines et les communes
s'illumine peu à peu et organisent leur
traditionnel marché de noël
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week-end
bixente qui n'attend que ça de sortir
dans les facs te ment même s'il fait un
peu froid en ce moment on débute on
musique avec un jeune rappeur que l'on
suit régulièrement sur tv 78 le rappeur
saint quentinois kirtas sera ce soir en
première partie du concert de kery james
à la merise attrape ce matin il s'est
préparé il s'est fait tout beau chez le
barbier pour son rendez vous nous
l'avons donc rencontrer et c'est notre
interview express
[Musique]
je me présente bac heurte à 24 ans
rappeur ni mon teint
un artiste
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré c'est pas le
seul dans ma jeunesse mais
c'est l'un des artistes qui m'a qui m'a
inspiré et du coup on novembre 2018
j'avais sortir un morceau en son nom qui
avait plutôt bien marché qui avait été
validée par le parquet james rumeurs
parfois je crois percevoir madame
espoirs drapeau blanc main mais ce n'est
qu'un mirage car aussi bizarre que cela
puisse sembler lac est rempli plus de
bouche en plus plus de poche et de
porte-monnaie que son ennemi la paix
je vais interpréter
trois chansons de mon projet 7 km 8 une
chanson que j'ai fait quand j'étais plus
jeune
donc on va bien évidemment aussi le
parmi les trois il y aura le morceau
kery james
et je vais faire au mars est aussi le
premier à trappes
[Musique]
son
même cédé france n'est pas parce
pas toi
pour mars
marçais
pour voter tourner une sauce
au bled loger
du coup j'enchaîne donc demain soir je
fais mon premier concert officiel donc
j'ai fait beaucoup de scène j'ai fait
des tremplins des fêtes de la musique
j'ai fait pas mal d'événements mais
demain soir c'est mon concert c'est
voilà ma billetterie ce qui est sûr
c'est que après ce week-end ouais je
pense qu'
une page va se fermer pour en ouvrir une
autre bien sûr mais c'est vraiment une
consécration bon je crois bixente
contient un nouveau concept l'interview
embauché coiffeur une interview barbier
peut-être la présentation bientôt
faire coiffer même temps si bien besoin
on parlait tout à l'heure du téléthon il
ya un autre rendez vous forts du mois de
décembre bixente et à la proche des
fêtes on aime le retrouver sont les
gregory les marchés de noël l'occasion
rêvée pour acheter des spécialités
locales rencontrer les commerçants
artisans faire de la patinoire ou tout
simplement prendre un petit chocolat
chaud ce petit moment de détente qui
symbolise l'arrivée de noël des fêtes
nous on s'est rendu il ya quelques jours
de cela du côté de
montigny-le-bretonneux qui préparé son
marché pour ce week-end regardez le
marché de noël de montigny le bretonneux
se tiendra ici même les 3 4 et 5
décembre prochains après une année où il
n'a pas pu se tenir en physique il est
de retour ici à la ferme du manet et
nous ne recevons josé cache un élu à la
commune de montigny retenue à la culture
et l'événementiel bonjour bonjour donc
bien sûr tout n'est pas installée mais
normalement à l'heure où vous voyez ce
sida à l'écran tout sera prêt tout sera
déjà en place puisque le vendredi le
marché sera déjà ouvert monsieur cache
un heureux de retrouver les yvelinois
ici très heureux ça nous manquait
terriblement
ce marché de noël et notamment une
nouvelle implantation
que l'on a souhaité afin de pouvoir
convivial is est un petit peu cet
événement donc on aura toujours le
nombre d'exposants qui était prévu les
années précédentes c'est à dire autour
de 130 exposants
80 en intérieur une cinquantaine en
extérieur mais cette année en terme de
nouveauté un espace de restauration
chauffer pour inciter les yvelinois à se
rendre sur marché de noël et à profiter
des spécialités régionales pour se
restaurer sur place oui parce qu'ici on
est dans la grande salle mais comme vous
le disait en extérieur il ya aussi la
deuxième partie sur l'aménagement le but
c'est de rendre tout ça convivial en
fait ça a été revu pour ça oui oui le
côté convivial
qui me paraît extrêmement important le
fait que les gens puissent se retrouver
enfin malgré le contexte qui est encore
très compliqué aujourd'hui et j'en
profite pour rappeler la nécessité du
pass sanitaires mais aussi le port du
masque qui sera obligatoire à
l'intérieur de cette manifestation mais
en tout cas oui le plaisir que tout le
monde puisse se rencontrer un niveau et
que ce ne soit pas uniquement un espace
destiné à acheter
des spécialités et à repartir mais
plutôt passer un temps de convivialité
tous ensemble
à un moment donné ce qui explique aussi
les horaires plus larges que nous aurons
sur ce marché de noël puisque le
vendredi et le samedi le marché noël
sera ouvert de 10h à 21h d'accord de 10
heures à 19 heures le dimanche parmi les
animations le week-end des déambulations
dans le village oui alors très
rapidement sur l'inauguration qui se
déroulera le vendredi soir ce jour là
aujourd'hui ce soir à 20 heures à 18
heures pardon avec une batucada qui sera
mise en place
lumineuse donc une déambulation
lumineuse et puis des animations tout au
long du week-end avec la présence de
mascotte qui viendront animer cet
événement est bien sûr moi j'ai grandi
dans le coin ici et dans mon enfance
j'étais habitué au père noël à voir le
père noël a rencontré le père noël ici
il ya le traditionnel chalet du père
noël incontournable
on aura la maison du père noël cette
année dès ce soir bien évidemment les
enfants pourront profiter de la présence
du père noël
au travers de photos pour immortaliser
ce moment mais le père noël sera bien
évidemment présent également samedi et
dimanche étant donné les événements il
ne pouvait que répondre par la positive
et pour terminer rapidement le ce que
vous faisiez c'est que le marché est en
pleine évolution vous souhaitez le
transformer sur les prochaines années
également quelle direction prend le
marché de montigny ce que nous
souhaiterions et ce qui sera très
probablement l'objet de cette évolution
qu'on aura dans les années à venir c'est
de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
inciter en quelque sorte les familles
alors pour les plus anciens continuent à
venir se restaurer sur place mais et
surtout pour les plus jeunes
renforcer encore un peu plus ce côté là
de vestiges auprès des plus petits
autour d'animations qui s'implanteront
comme ça au fil du temps merci jaser
cash en avoir été avec nous du coup on
retrouver tout le week-end sur la ferme
du mané le marché de noël de
montigny-le-bretonneux et je vais
revenir du coup rapidement sur deux
petites particules et particularités du
marché de montigny cette année des
représentants des trois villes jumelées
à la 2 3 des villes jumelées à la ville
seront présents les anglais de denton
les irlandais de lynch henson et les
romains de l'omca et autres petites
infos pratiques des navettes gratuites
sont mises à disposition toutes les 30
minutes pour faciliter l'accès et
montigny le bretonneux ouvrira en fait
bixente le grand bal des marchés noël
qui aura lieu dans le département oui
les rendez-vous continuer à vendre
jusqu'à la fin du mois le week-end
prochain ce sera au tour de la verrière
voisins le bretonneux magny les hameaux
maurepas et plaisir pensez bien à
vérifier sur les sites internet ou
réseaux sociaux des communes pour les
heures et les dates par exemple du côté
de la verrière qui n'est que la journée
du samedi 11 décembre mais en tout cas
peu importe les communes il y aura des
choses à faire regarder par exemple un
plaisir ce que nous annonce madame le
maire y aurait de l'orgue de barbarie
aussi présence de musiciens il n'y aura
la ferme une ferme mini-ferme ira les
les promenades en calèche avec nos
chevaux bien sûr avec aussi distribution
de vin chaud et distribution de chocolat
vous à dire en est très porté sur le vin
chaud mais enfin quoi qui fait très très
près c'est plutôt sympa on va aussi
faire une petite bifurcation et sortir
rapidement de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
puisque le département des yvelines
anime aussi ce week end là son comptoir
de noël rendez vous donc les 11 et 12
décembre domaine madame elisabeth à
versailles et rapidement voilà il reste
les marchés de villepreux et l'encours
est de trappes entre le 17 et le 21
décembre avec de nombreuses fait rien
dans le reste du département vous en
parliez déjà mais exactement grégory
dans le sud des yvelines à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet par exemple
dans le nord à houilles enfin un peu
partout finalement et si on est chanceux
vu les températures on aura peut-être un
peu de neige qui sait grégory ça
renforcerait l'esprit de noël je sais
que vous y êtes attaché lee shalit et on
va parler de danse on va danser un petit
peu dans cette émission oui le théâtre
alexandre dumas organise régulièrement
des rencontres entre les artistes de sa
programmation et les yvelinois cette
fois c'était avec des enfants un petit
atelier de hip hop animé par un danseur
de la compagnie art move concept jackson
regardée on va faire trois groupes
différents moi faire la même chose
jackson danseurs pour la compagnie art
move concept animé un petit atelier de
hip hop à l'école des sources de saint
germain en laye on a fait des pas sur le
côté en arrière aussi quand on se
croisait j'adorais les plateaux tence et
pourquoi et mais j'aimerais raufer
hockey le recul reculer passage très
très accessible pour qu'ils puissent
avoir ça leur donne envie en tout cas où
un aperçu de ce que c'est la danse j'ai
déjà avoir le rythme et de bouger dans
l'espace déjà ça leur apprend déjà
beaucoup de choses
mr d'apprentissage pour les 18 enfants
présents pour une chorégraphie finale
nicole pied à droite à gauche et l'autre
ont reculé en
arrière et le plus difficile on met tes
genoux à j'étais motivé donc c'est ça
qui est ça qui est cool c'est que
lorsqu'ils sont motivés ça même pas moi
ça me ça me donne envie d'aller encore
plus loin de leur donner beaucoup plus
de choses et quand jackson montre aux
enfants de quoi il est capable lorsque
s'illumine ça m'a impressionné choqué je
trouve que ça ça doit des années
d'entraînement et que en fait c'est et
je suis content pour lui qu'il a fait ça
en légère aperçu du mardi 7 décembre au
théâtre alexandre dumas de saint germain
en laye neuf danseurs de la compagnie
art nouveau concept seront sur scène
pour le spectacle à nos pains j'aimerais
bien le voir je suis sûr que ce sera
bien parce que quand j'ai vu bien axel
je mets 10 ça ferait ordinaires dont ses
spectacles en mai on a essayé en tout
cas de des véhicules et
la complexité d'être d'être artiste de
données entre guillemets de montrer un
peu comment c'était quel est notre
univers parc on est passés par des joies
des peines des difficultés un deuxième
atelier similaire à celui ci sera animée
par jackson le 8 décembre prochain
bon me chantez vous aviez déjà relevé le
défi en plateau de chanter le prochain
c'est de danser une petite danse hip hop
on avance à face un jour avec impatience
donc le spectacle de jackson c'est mardi
prochain mais ça ça jackson et sa petite
troupe pour anno pas ce sera mardi
prochain le 7 décembre à 20h45 au
théâtre alexandre dumas avance à samedi
quatre donc ce samedi un concert de
louis chedid qui nous présente son album
tout ce qu'on veut dans la vie et la
semaine d'après le 14 décembre
rimbaud en feu un spectacle autour du
célèbre poète avec un acteur notamment
que j'aime beaucoup jean pierre
darroussin mais justement pour les
agendas du week-end à venir on va au
château de versailles dès la semaine
prochaine c'est toute une expérience qui
vous attend au château une visite
spectacle à la tombée de la nuit le
parcours du roi c'est une déambulation
animée entre la galerie des glaces et
les grands appartements soul ambiance
baroque ça débute donc samedi 12
décembre il y aura cinq séances à chaque
fois entre 18h et 19h 40 pour les dates
le premier soir donc le 12 décembre et à
partir du 19 ce sera tous les samedis et
dimanches mardis et mercredis pendant
deux semaines et pour les tarifs ils
vont de 31 à 48 euros il faut réserver
sur le site chateauversailles tirer
spectacle n'a pas le soleil on peut se
replonger aussi dans l'époque de pauline
viardot la cantatrice et compositrice de
bougival mais en effet pour célébrer son
bicentenaire le conservatoire de musique
de bougival vous donne rendez vous pour
un concert de noël l'opéra le dernier
sorcier de pauline viardot se jouera
dimanche 12 décembre à 11 heures et une
deuxième représentation à 16 heures
c'est un orchestre donc assemblé par les
élèves et les professeurs du
conservatoire qui jouera les deux
représentations merci bixente pour tout
ce programme et c'est déjà la fin est de
7,8 week-end on se retrouve bien sûr
vendredi prochain pour une nouvelle
émission un très bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]